guillaume ensemble à paris il a eu les
meilleurs résultats ne lisez pas non on
se dise non formaté j concrètes
sa passion que tu dis là prochain
lettres supérieures et en deux ans il a
toutes les chances d'entrer anormal de
tenir sans faille débouchés assurés
la raison pour laquelle sans doute la
vie professionnelle n'est pas possible
médias
plus que les autres dernière en fait
comme la plupart de ses camarades de
classe
si cette mention très bien bas guillon
n'a que l'embarras du choix de sa
carrière à lutry grâce à des actes issus
de la télé classieux mais aussi à force
de travail ambitions de tous entrés dans
les grandes écoles polytechnique ou
normale
je crois qu'ils sont capables de gérer
leurs idées
c'est possible en attendant millions